trash talking ufc fighter and the king
of miami jorge maz vidal he joins me now
all right so jorge you're
son of the cuban exiles how do you or
how would your family feel about being
told to shut up about tyranny
first i don't know why they send our
athletes to china that's crazy and how
you doing man if i'm honored to be on
your show my brother i don't know why
they sent the american athletes over
there if it's such a problem that they
can't even speak on the matters you know
so it's crazy and my parents of course i
i know what they would say you know what
they would say they said this leads to
what cuba is now what venezuela is now
leads to communism you know and we have
to stop it as soon as we get a chance
yeah you take their phones away from you
and if you start saying something some
goon will tackle you
i don't know why nancy didn't say this
if the chinese communists touch a hair
on one of our bobsledders one of our
curlers one of our downhill skiers
they will be met with the full force of
the u.s government
case closed why can't nancy just say
that jorge
is not for the american people you know
we've had other leaders in power that
would have made sure no american got
touched if not they wouldn't send them
if they if it was that much of a
situation they could put him at risk so
it's crazy it's just nuts america has
changed you know i have uh i have an
uncle that passed away five years ago if
if he came back right now and i had to
explain them all the issues that have
happened in these last five years he'd
be in the twilight zone it's crazy
everything that's going on
from the pandemic mandates to you know
you can't be out in the street but you
have to be robbing and stealing like
it's crazy you know they shut down
businesses
all across the country and we're still
now finally coming back and it's still a
lot of nonsense going on man it's nuts i
got so many questions why is the gas so
high like
i'm a simpleton right can somebody
explain that to me really quick you know
i could be other things promoting my
fight but i love this country man i
really do and i have so many questions
and they don't get answered you know
yeah we're gonna promote the hell out of
your fight in a second but i'm just
curious say they had mma in the olympics
i mean god helped the chinese if they
did but say you were over there
competing and someone put a mic in your
face and they asked you
what's going on there during your trip
what would you say
i mean if they were smart enough that
they didn't let me see any of that crazy
stuff then maybe i couldn't say crazy
but if i saw something that needs to be
spoken about why not you know and um
get on the first private plane added as
soon as i say that they're going to come
looking for me
so it it's crazy though i just uh i
don't even think i would have gotten
over that i've never been a cuba i
haven't been to any communist countries
my dad's strictly just for busy for me
he just doesn't want me to so i don't
know if i would have been able to
compete in that game i'm not in that
situation so i don't i don't say but i
know my dad would have been
sternly against it you know yeah it's a
very tough choice all right so uh we
have a big fight coming up march 5th 10
o'clock eastern ufc 272 you're facing
off against kobe covington who came on
prime time last week here is what he
said about you roll it
yeah march 5th it's a career ending
fight for jorge monstadol he's talked a
big game jesse to the media and just
like joe biden they talk a big game but
they don't walk a big game and and march
5th on pay-per-view i'm going to expose
journeyman jorge mossman in front of the
world oh he called you a journeyman
what's your response jorge
it's so amazing that i'm going to get to
punch this guy in the face
and i really don't like this guy and i'm
going to get paid for a big amount of
money
and i can't wait just to expose him once
again to the world he's a charlatan he's
um
you know if you don't believe me just
ask him any what's his favorite law that
trump passed while trump wasn't
presidency or anything like that assad
idi anything politically related you see
he's just a fraud man he's just holding
up books to get triggers and things like
that but he doesn't know anything about
what he talks about and about fighting
he's very limited and i'm going to show
him march first how limited he is all
right i'll be watching you know however
much it costs i'll be doing the
pay-per-view thing it's going to be a
great fight don't forget yep donald
trump's favorite fighter don't forget
brother
all right jorge thank you so much for
coming on jesse waters prime time
god bless america god bless america do
the right thing ron desantis greatest
governor in power right now all right we
got a ron desantis shout out hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else